pensilvania otorga 20 votos electorales
lo que equivale a la mayor cantidad que
aún queda por definir
así las cosas y throne gana en este
estado aseguraría la reelección en medio
de la incertidumbre los habitantes se
muestran divididos pero confiados en que
la decisión final no genere hechos
violentos en su territorio
no creo que aquí haya violencia en todo
eeuu creo que podría haberla ya sabes
hemos tenido muchos disturbios y esas
cosas y creo que podríamos ver eso pero
no por aquí no lo creo
no arriba
es el día después de las elecciones y
ahora tenemos que esperar 4 días para
saber quién ganó eso es absolutamente
absurdo va a hacer lo que necesite para
llenar sus propios bolsillos y los
bolsillos de la gente que está moviendo
los hilos dice muchas cosas para la
gente pero honestamente que ha hecho en
los últimos cuatro años nada
de acuerdo con lo indicado por el
gobernador de este estado demócrata tom
wolfe todavía restan por ser contados
más de un millón de votos por correo por
lo que los señalamientos de trump sobre
el presunto fraude serían solo parte de
un ataque partidista con 12 millones 700
mil habitantes pensilvania es el sexto
estado más poblado del país uno en el
que a diferencia de otros como georgia
los votos por correo no fueron
procesados con antelación por lo que
trump afirma que las papeletas contadas
desde el cierre de las urnas serían
fraudulentas